well the basic premise of the project
was that I was hoping to find out about
as much about myself as I could and
specifically my DNA without any of the
sort of safeguards that you would expect
that you would have to go through in
order to get that sort of information I
didn't go through a doctor I didn't
register with a genetic counselor there
was nobody getting me ready for what the
results of my tests would be my
intention was to be out there in kind of
the wilds of the internet with just me
and my credit card these companies had
no idea who I was I was just buying data
companies were selling DNA tests
offering you a variety of different
stories about your life the DNA tests
which was sold on fear so they were
offers to package your DNA store your
DNA allow you to identify children
who've gone missing or make it easier to
identify you if you were killed DNA
tests which offered to tell you
something fundamental about your history
so they would tell you where your family
came from where your DNA came from the
great myths of your past tests which
offered to predict the future for you
they would tell you when you would die
what illnesses you would get finally the
testers who were just offering you fun
essentially they would make you a
necklace or a t-shirt or a stained-glass
window or a tie based on some fairly
unimportant bits of your DNA sequence
most of the tests required that you take
cheek cell swap so basically get an
oversized q-tip and rub it quite hard on
the inside of each cheek and underneath
your tongue you have to be quite harsh
when you do it it hurts your your time
in your cheeks will smart afterwards if
you do it properly
such great people total risk for so I'm
holding in my hands the result of an
ancestry test which I have done and this
is a an autosomal DNA test so they
tested all my DNA to find out where it
come from in the world and what my deep
kind of ancestral roots are according to
this are 92% European six percent East
Asian two percent sub-saharan African
and zero percent Native American i have
to admit i was hoping for something a
little bit more interesting i have here
the results of another one of my tests
i've had something called the actn three
gene tested elite sportsman tend to have
one particular form and the rest of us
have a different format entirely so it
turns out i'm not going to be a great
footballer when I grow up but on the
other hand there's ever anything I need
to do for a very long time I have a lot
of stamina I have a very low risk of
glaucoma thankfully I do however have a
very high risk of age-related macular
degeneration so there's a good chance
that my eyes are going to pack in when I
get older she's not the best news I've
had all day the DNA test results that
I've just had through it from a company
looking at a variety of different genes
forming on one of the genes that they're
telling me about is called apoe and
they're very happy to tell me all about
my apoe results because I've got two
versions of this gene both of which are
the same and they're both called a pro
III it would tend to mean I have a lower
cholesterol level the other good thing
that they haven't mentioned is that
having two copies of apoe three means
that i don't have the high risk a pony
for version which would mean i would be
more likely to develop Alzheimer's later
in life and the other great thing about
this is that if I don't have any copies
of it that means neither of my parents
has enough copies to have a high risk
allele either so I'm now reviewing
another test they've tested for genes
which are involved in venous thrombosis
there is something slightly worrying in
here this is the first time that I've
had the words potentially high in bold
in capital letters in the section about
my risk level it turns out i have
genetic variations that are believed to
increase my risk over the general
population by a factor of about 50
thankfully I'm not old I'm not pregnant
i'm not using an oral contraceptive I'm
not a beast I don't have diabetes I've
not had any recent major surgery so all
of those factors are all right on but
the genetic factors I'm not doing very
well on at all a lot of these results if
I hadn't been a geneticist in the past I
would have opened them and probably been
quite scared why on earth would anyone
want to know all these things about
themselves I think I found out quite a
lot of little titbits about myself but
nothing that's particularly going to
change the way that I live my life I'm
not going to grow up to be a great
sportsman but then I'm 31 and working in
science I was never going to be a great
sportsman I might get fat when I get old
my eyes might not work I might get heart
disease I think that's true of
absolutely everybody I've learned some
fairly meaningless things about myself
supposedly I'm related to a woman who
lived in Italy 15,000 years ago and
supposedly I have the most European DNA
at anyone you're likely to meet I don't
think either of those is going to change
the way that I live my life